mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
schule aus der ferne während corona
digital
unser fokus heute die einen jubeln zwtl
händigen wie sie für schulentwicklung
sport die anderen warnen wenn wir unsere
datenschutzgesetze der muss man ganz
klar sagen dort sehr viele sachen
gemacht so einfach illegal sind
das wäre jetzt die chance dass man die
schule neu denken könnte welches fazit
ziehen bildungsexperten und was meinen
lernen will zum digitalen unterricht und
kommuniziert
[Musik]
wie kommen auf dem ersten kulturplatz
nach der sommerpause unser ziel heute
die kunstbiennale art safiental hier
gibt es über 30 kilometer verteilt kunst
zu entdecken
[Musik]
wer sich jetzt denkt das ist eine
richtig analoge sache hier mitten in der
natur der täuscht sich
wenn die art safiental bewegt sich ganz
bewusst zwischen der analogen und der
digitalen welt das schauen wir uns an
dem genau gleichen spannungsfeld stand
in den vergangenen monaten unser
schulsystem der bisher ziemlich analoge
schulbetrieb musste mit einem lock darum
quasi über nacht digital werden
eine riesige herausforderung für kinder
lehrer und eltern wir fragen hat die
institution schule diese prüfung
bestanden
was hat die schule gelernt in der zeit
des fernunterrichts wo steht sie heute
in sachen digitalisierung erste station
der bestandesaufnahme orb und im seeland
in der agglomeration von bild am
oberstufenzentrum hat der unterricht
wieder im schulzimmer begonnen ohne
masken pflicht alaba ist ein lehrer wie
er im buch steht er ist 64 und hätte
eigentlich bald in pension gehen können
doch die korona krise hat ihn dazu
bewogen noch ein jahr anzuhängen von
fernunterricht ist er nicht überzeugt
dass reagierten wie die belastung schwer
oder effekt noch ausgesehen
natürlich überzeugt dass die schule wie
sie jetzt ich das ganze auto
fernunterricht weg überlegen ist also
die frage wie froh dass man wieder in
eine soziale engagement können lernen
wie lernen soziale prozesse schlechten
das ist sozialer prozess und der mensch
lernt durch den menschen netto schon
bekannt sein
so die sicht des lehrers doch sieht dies
seine klasse genau so akkurat sozialer
kraut also mädels die verlängerung
school in hamburg sehr gute aber keine
probleme
es ist schwierig wenn man opel ehemals
und what's up kommuniziert dass sie die
haut in der simulation die aufgabe
zusammen macht zu mich jetzt nicht
wirklich gut brauchen
ein heterogenes bild bestätigt durch das
so genannte schul barometer eine
erhebung der pädagogischen hochschule
zug
die einen kamen gut zurecht lernten
gleich viel oder sogar mehr
die anderen hängten ab und nutzen den
lock down als vorgezogene ferien
unterschiede zeigen sich auch bei den
lehrpersonen es gibt die digitalisierung
muffel und die digitalisierung turbos
denen die entwicklung nicht schnell
genug gehen kann wie etwa priska fuchs
sie unterrichtet fremdsprachen in zug am
kaufmännischen berufsbildungszentrum es
ist der letzte schultag vor den
sommerferien noch ist hier
fernunterricht standard das
klassenzimmer leer alle am bildschirm
versammelt was man natürlich noch nicht
gemacht ist dass der verhandlung recht
und ich glaub ich dem bereich miliz
wirkliche große schritte nach vorne
machen
so präsentiert nun eine schülerin ihre
textanalyse digital und vorgefertigt
ich werde gar ausschließen du hast
gesagt du hast das mit berg gemacht mit
video wie war das für dich das arbeiten
mit diesem tool glaube jeder gerne was
neues aus an schweizer schulen ist eine
art kulturkampf rund um das digitale
lernen entbrannt die einen wollen noch
mehr drängen darauf den schwung von
corona zu nutzen
andere bremsen sehen gefahren und
benachteiligungen in der digitalen welt
wie löst man dieses dilemma wir fragen
nach bei margrit stamm die renommierte
erziehungswissenschaftlerin beschäftigt
sich seit langem mit der frage was es
für gutes lernen braucht mehr müsste
probieren spechten aus der analogen und
beste neue digitale welt zu setzen und
das verschmelzen der hat es gemerkt dass
man präsenz bezieht das man dir net do
digitalisierten wenn politiker salz und
jetzt möglichst schnell digitalisieren
und wenn das nummer heißt alles auf
geräte bringen
denn ist das für mich nicht mit die die
pädagogen ich mir vorstelle
das ist wasser auf die mühlen der
digitalisierung skeptiker wie al arabija
zu viel aktivität im netz erhöhe den
lerneffekt nicht ist er überzeugt
woga katar trennt ist also man muss
schüler nicht nur der computer frauen
die junge ihnen bringen
die in die digitale medienwelt sondern
nur sehr eigentlich ende verdammt war
kolumbien wo andere sache machen und das
ist auch von schulen und nicht einfach
kapitulieren
das machen wir das alles wie es ist was
der lockt auch gezeigt hat datenschutz
ist ein problem so viel einblick ins
private hatten die lehrer noch nie mit
der webcam direkt ins kinderzimmer oder
wohnzimmer jeder schülerin und jedes
schülers und mit weitgehenden
möglichkeiten diese bei der arbeit zu
überwachen
das geht etwa so der schüler hat quasi
ihr programm wo sowohl mutter war
schaffte wie auch lehrer wodurch jetzt
wie kontrolliere ich vertraue macht das
nicht das gut für mich sieht das tut mir
dadurch mit würdet persönlichkeit
untergraben durch fast ganz weg alter
nicht wenn es nur darum geht die stoffe
für 1 bis 100 allenfalls nicht gemacht
hätte oder im krieg und ich gerne
klarheit nicht am richtigen ort gemacht
denn ist natürlich nicht richtig aber es
hilft mir die lernende besser kann als
lehre aus zeitpunkt wenn ich koche frage
was ist oft versuchen die probleme oft
auf der grund scorsese verstehe und
letztlich gott
anders als sie wieder zu bringen
und wenn mir der analyse tools helfen
[Musik]
viele lehrkräfte und eltern verunsichert
auch dass großkonzerne wie microsoft
oder google daten profile von benutzern
sammeln wenn wir unsere tat und
datenschutz gesetz sieht der muss man
ganz klar sagen mir handel sehr viele
sachen gemacht war illegal sind ja das
ist so das ist das ist großes problem
und ich denke das muss man auch
gesellschaftlich lösen also es kommt sie
dass jeder lehrer sich zuerst muss
gedanken darüber machen und analysieren
was ist das tool falsch oder richtig
machen dass es muss so reglementiert
sieht dass ich eigentlich mit einer gute
gefühl sowie genau das versucht in der
schweiz die fachagentur edeka punkt ch
im auftrag von bund und kantonen
sie handelt mit den wichtigen anbietern
verträge aus ab diesem herbst soll zudem
der zugang zu verschiedenen lernt als
mittels eines einzigen block ins
vereinfacht und sicherer werden
fazit das schweizerische schulsystem hat
den digitalisierungs test im
fernunterricht insgesamt recht gut
bestanden das schul barometer zeigt
einen leichten vorsprung auf unsere
nachbarländer zb in der ausrüstung mit
geräten
was braucht es für die zukunft nach
corona pädagogik die taktische frage und
und jeglichem ulrike was lehrer schüler
was hat sie gelehrt wie hans ist-zustand
warum es bestand das weg in das sehen
wir stehen uns anstatt ihnen innerhofer
technologie natürlich darum was ich sie
lernen
die junge menschen in zukunft flucht
respektiv als jäger braucht und das ist
auf der einen seite wirklich der umgang
mit einem medien medienkompetenz werde
das ist ein fester bestandteil vom
lehrplan 21
aber es geht natürlich auch darum dass
sie wirklich kompetente sie könnte im
bereich kreativität flexibel
die resilienz sie um das leben einfach
nicht mitgerechnet
wenn es wirklich mit springt dass man
jetzt acht wochen sprint den ich das
sehr gut
wenn es aber einen dauerlauf wird also
wenn wir jetzt sagen es ist zwar nach
gronau
aber es ist vielleicht vor dem nächsten
pandemie der krisenmodus eigentlich
stelle
denn sind wir natürlich war das nicht
als einmalige angelegenheit ups tour
sondern wie mich anfangs überlegt wie
man jetzt das ganze pulver krisenfester
machen und eben moderner team aufbauen
dazu braucht es aber eine wirkliche
transformation nicht bloß ein
digitalisieren von papieren den
arbeitsblättern daran wird sich die
schule in zukunft messen müssen
[Musik]
was die kabarettistin und ehemalige
lehrerin partie basler von der digitalen
schule hält das sehen sie online
[Musik]
nach einem spaziergang durch den wald
sind wir hier angekommen beim
stillgelegten aktuell und diesen tunnel
hat die bündner künstlerin ester vonplon
in den letzten wochen als atelier
genutzt und sogar als fotokamera
[Musik]
sie hat dem düsteren und nasskalten
tunnel fotopapier ausgelegt durch
winzige löcher viel licht aus einem
seiten stollen und auf das papier
entstanden sind diese eindrücklichen
schwarz weiß und farbfotografien die man
nun im tunneleingang bewundern kann
[Musik]
kunst ausstellungen wie diese sind unter
den gegebenen umständen natürlich ideal
an der frischen luft wir wissen alle
corona ist nicht vorbei das bedeutet für
die meisten kunstschaffenden nach wie
vor keine arbeit kein lohn und daran
dürfte sich auch mit dem neuen gesetz
das vom bundesrat verabschiedet wurde
letzte woche nichts ändern dabei hätte
es durchaus gute ideen gegeben wie die
lebensbedingungen von kreativen in der
krise verbessert werden können aber eben
hätte unter diesem dach wurden schon
viele wichtige entscheide gefällt
am letzten mittwoch war es wieder mal
soweit die landesregierung hat das kit
19 gesetzte arbeitet das gesetz
behandelt unter anderem maßnahmen zum
schutz unserer gesundheit klar oder
entschädigungsfragen für arbeitnehmende
die kultur kommt auch vor
im artikel 7 der erste satz ist auch der
bemerkenswerteste
[Musik]
der bundesrat kann kulturunternehmen und
kulturschaffende mit finanzhilfen
unterstützen die autorin bettina spoerri
schrieb im juni einen brief an den
bundesrat
ihre forderung ein monatlicher
festbetrag von 2300 franken für
selbstständige kultur schaffen
die jetzige gesetzes version ist hier
viel zu wenig konkret das fleisch und
das lippenbekenntnis bleiben aber es
langt einfach nicht sagen
kultur ist systemrelevant und denn alles
andere zu machen oder weil über
behandelt kulturen im land wo man mit
wir wenn sie systemrelevant wäre so
schwer die entscheidung des spiels auch
in dem gesetz was und maßnahmen für den
kulturbereich geordnet sage man kann der
bund kaum unterstützen
ich meine das nicht ein einschnitt
wichtige entscheide das jetzt wieder
anders bei der eidgenössischen
kulturförderung sieht man den
sachverhalt anders
der bundesrätliche gesetzesvorschlag so
phillip bischof bedeute dass die
fördermaßnahmen weitergehen weitere 110
millionen franken gesprochen werden
lippenbekenntnis ganz im gegenteil sagt
ihr zwei millionen
das ist 400 millionen euro das die
stochastiks meeres liegt beginnt ist
insofern nämlich glaubt die bundesweit
elektras zeit gesprochen
ich bin zuversichtlich das parlament
dann folgt und glaube das ist viel für
die bedürfnisse der iwf griffen dem
kanton der zürcher regierungsrätin
jacqueline fehr gingen ein fünftel aller
anträge der schweizerin eine
administrative herkulesaufgabe deshalb
schlug sie vor einen sogenannten
sockelbeitrag für selbständige
kulturschaffende im gesetz zu verankern
der bundesrat hat dies abgelehnt andres
veiel thomas kann das probiere gaza mit
weniger bürokratie und boards auch mit
mehr bessere verhältnis von aufwand und
ertrag und unter dem strich das kann ich
garantieren unterm strich rutschte
gegenstücke wenn man einfach pauschal
ihnen 2000 franken gewährt die vier auf
die prozess verzichtet und mit einer
wurde für mehr wirklich sehr genau
erläutert und magna überprüfen
der bundesrat sieht das anders
noch im märz beschloss die
landesregierung die kultur ist teil des
hilfspakets und damit systemrelevant ein
kulturpolitischer meilenstein
jetzt wo das notrecht ein ordentliches
gesetz überführt werden muss fällt auf
die maßnahmen für den kulturbereich sind
deutlich weniger konkret als zum
beispiel jene im medienbereich
warum eigentlich störer ein verrücktes
machen als provozierend ärgere dass ich
als lobby für aussetzer idee aber das
ist ja total auftrag der kultur machen
die frage stelle es gibt immerhin in
chodziez stimme und der bundesrat zwar
sei das ist systemrelevant
aber es gibt natürlich die gesellschaft
an auch viele andere stimmen und dass
das noch nicht ganz fest ich das buch
bettina spoerri fragt sich derweil wann
eigentliche eigener
unterstützungsbeitrag ausbezahlt wird
sie hatte im mai eingereicht und bis
jetzt nichts bekommen bleibt das gesetz
so wie es ist so die autorin werde die
qualität der kulturellen produktion
massiv leiden werde
internationale kunstmesse produzieren
wenn bin da die ganze basis wegbricht
und uhrmacher künstler sich andere prüft
prüft notgedrungenes suche dann muss ich
einfach sehr guten abschluss der kunst
in dem land und er warnt aber dem
internet meine das thema irgendwie
relevante die kritik und ängste der
selbständigen kulturschaffenden kennt
philipp bischof bestens weniger vielfalt
in der kulturellen welt befürchtet er
nicht
darlegung bedürfnis diese immens und die
sind sehr unterschiedlich und dort für
kohärenz und wirkungsvolles gesetzt
vielen der mann sind sehr scharfe und
darum sage ich es ist sehr gut der
kompromiss es ist nicht erledigt war
alles wert ob denke dass du kein gesetz
aber ich stand dazu eine tiefe bezüglich
sich sehr gut die basis in die
diskussion geht weiter im parlament in
der kommenden herbstsession dann wird
definitiv entschieden über konkrete
maßnahmen über viele existenzen im
kulturbereich und damit auch wie ernst
des bundes bern mit der systemrelevanz
ist
wir bleiben dran
[Musik]
hier geht's digital weiter und zwar hier
hinter dieser haus ecke mit dem qr code
des künstlers patrick rohner sein werk
sehen wir mittels dem kot hier können
wir starten
die natur kennt keine katastrophen heißt
es
[Musik]
oder wieso auf die folgen des
klimawandels aufmerksam machen
die qr codes zu seiner arbeit sind im
safiental genau an jenen stellen
platziert die aus gefahrenzonen für
lawinenabgang erdrutsch hochwasser oder
werkstätten jetzt einer gefahr hätte
dieses jahr auch das zürcher theater
spektakel werden können
größere menschenansammlungen gilt es
nach wie vor zu vermeiden denn corona
ist noch immer da aber die festival
leitung des zürcher theaterspektakels
hat sich davon nicht in die knie zwingen
lassen und hat auch dieses jahr ein
politisches und poetisches theater
festival auf die beine gestellt nur
kleiner dezentraler und mit neuen formen
wie führt man theater auf in zeiten der
pandemie
man nehme einen kopfhörer ein handy und
gehe aufs schiff ich sehe viele
unterschiede gar gegensätze zwischen
zürich und städten in mexiko besonders
aber beeindruckt mich der schiere
überfluss an kristallklaren wasser oder
das theater fährt gleich selber los geht
in die stadtquartiere und spielt vor
nicht allzu vielen leuten
[Musik]
theaterspektakel direktor matthias von
hartz trotz der pandemie und setzt in
schwierigen zeiten auf die etwas andere
form des theaters
wir haben uns eigentlich sofort gegen
verkleinerte vorstellungen entschieden
und dann gesagt wir probieren höher was
neues aus als das gleiche in schlechter
oder kleiner zu machen
also leute sitzen im dunkeln und einer
hustet und einer hustet immer fanden wir
auch einfach nicht attraktiv
das gewagteste experiment am
diesjährigen festival aber spielt dann
doch tränen im stück virus sind die
zuschauer gleichzeitig die spieler
eingeteilt in acht gruppen wie behörden
presse forschung oder wirtschaft müssen
sie zusammen ein land durch eine
pandemie viren als 1 assist noch im
ausland beweist dass das kommen wert
muss sich vorbereiten
die zweite phase ist baff es fängt an in
denen land es hat aber das lag aber noch
nicht richtig los es hat schon ein paar
kranken vielleicht auch ein paar an
toten aber es ist noch nicht wichtig
dort hat es die dritte phase da geht so
groß das ist großer spitz und dann kommt
man raus oder man bereitet sich vor auf
die nächste welle jan dinter krad
zusammen mit einem arzt und zwei gehen
designern ein spiel entwickelt basierend
auf simulationen früherer pandemien in
dem fall ist es eine aggressive
vogelgrippe aus dem jahr 2013
das spiel wurde tatsächlich noch vor
corona entwickelt
machen sie den games ländern bei der
suche nach einem impfstoff geben sie
eine banknote aus und lesen sie wie
folge karte 24
ich würde mehr die bulligen fixiert ist
ich bin von der sicherheit und wir
hatten alle kämpfe einen fall
die mechanismen die verlautbarungen die
bedrohungen sind fast identisch mit den
vorkommnissen bei corona wenn es eine
bande mit einer pandemie hat dann hat
man keine dann hat man nie die richtige
information weil alles ist neu das hat
immer auf einmal 1000 experten die haben
alle art verschiedene theorien der
theorien und das geht tatsächlich von
knoblauch bis bridge oder und dazwischen
muss man irgendwie auswählen okay was
ist die wenig schlechte lösung im spiel
wie auch in der wirklichkeit treffen
sich immer wieder die wichtigsten
experten um über die zukunft des landes
zu entscheiden
bei uns gibt es gar nicht so viele
infizierte personen im moment schon
länger die grenzen geschlossen haben das
ist nicht bekannt
wir hatten diesen belgischen reisekarte
richtig schwarz gefahren ist und wir
hatten kontakt mit der schweizer
bevölkerung also die bombe tickte
dafür die grenzen zu schließen
der druck steigt fehler werden gemacht
und es sterben leute erhält die
forschung zu wenig geld gibt es keinen
impfstoff und ist daran da muss bestimmt
werden wir ihn kriegt denn er reicht
nicht für alle
[Musik]
die leute sehr gut wie sie vielleicht ja
wissen krisensituation virus trotzdem
live erlebt aber nicht so extrem
das zauberwort heißt zusammenarbeit
gehen die mitspieler aufeinander ein und
entscheiden für das große ganze geht es
glimpflich aus
kollaboration heißt doch das mantra für
das festival
mussten doch die internationalen
künstler aus der ferne mit den leuten
vor ort zusammenarbeiten
logos an wenn auch mit neuen vorzeichen
[Musik]
jetzt waren wir in den entlegensten
ecken des soffin 1000 sind nun zum
schluss zurück beim eingang in wall
enders und hier beim dorf bund zeige ich
ihnen ein letztes kunstwerk aber zu
beginn war sehen wir das gar nicht erst
wenn ich mein ipad auf diese fassade
richter entdecke ich die animation der
holländische künstler jan robert legte
hat sich von der bündner tradition des
graffito inspirieren lassen und bringt
sie zusammen mit neuen technologien
verschmelzungen von analog und digital
wie auch wunderbare erfrischungen die
gibt es hier bei der biennale im
safiental bis anfang november zu
entdecken
ich hoffe aber natürlich wir sehen uns
nächsten mittwoch bereits wieder da
nämlich nehmen wir sehen mit nach hause
und zwar zu ganz neuen klängen in einem
der besten musik tempel der welt was für
feine ohren auge und für diese noch ein
extra hinweis die musik in dieser
sendung stammt aus dem klavier tagebuch
von fremd lüchinger bleiben sie frisst
[Musik]
o
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos